j'avais que la vie politique française
est agité par cette triste affaire de la
radio libre du parti socialiste les
forces de l'ordre sont intervenues et
plusieurs journalistes ont été blessés
notamment notre cameraman dominique
merlet monsieur mitterrand qui est à
bruxelles en ce moment a déclaré je le
cite que son parti entend poursuivre sa
campagne de sensibilisation de l'opinion
publique contre la mainmise du pouvoir
sur les grands moyens d'information fin
de citation il ajoute que radio riposte
c'est le nom de cette radio libre fait
partie de la campagne que le parti
socialiste continue et et qu'ils
recommenceront donc réponse du ministre
de l'intérieur christian bonnet et je le
cite la loi s'applique à tous et
singulièrement à ceux qui sont chargés
de la faire il a ajouté je cite encore
ce n'est pas une décision politique que
de faire appliquer la loi fin de
citation vous l'imaginez cette affaire a
des répercussions à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat et le
vice-président du parlement monsieur
jacques antoine go à qualifier et je le
cite d'intolérable l'intervention de la
police cité malesherbes nous reviendrons
bien sûr sur cette affaire dans notre
journal de 20h avec pierre-alain qui
étaient sur les lieux au moment de
l'intervention policière avec daniel
brême et puis les commentaires de noël
copains